la emisión está comenzando todos los asistentes están en modo de sólo
escucha qué tal muy buenas tardes cómo estáis os saluda ser y sánchez una
clase más del curso de trading algorímico así que vamos a comenzar con
ello como siempre voy a escribirlo
los que me oís ya veo que me oís porque me estáis contestando pero si alguien no
me oye pues ya lo ya lo he escrito ya lo he escrito por ahí vale venga como
siempre empezamos atendiendo un poquito las las preguntas que hay en él sobre
todo en el disc or también voy a hacer algún comentario algún algún email y
luego vamos a trabajar bueno enseñaros cositas ideas que hemos trabajado
bastante en profundidad durante esta durante esa semana vale a ver el disco
el disco que está bueno ya ha visto ya lo que habíamos dejado comentado bueno
aquí antes voy la verdad que comentabas aquí en el disco que no conseguías que
te genera ningún trade y pues no no te sé no te sé decir con los datos que
pones ahí la verdad tienes la de arriba están estatus son la de abajo están
estatus no sé no sé si alberto se le ocurre algo que pueda provocar que la
estrategia no opere bueno quizás la sesión que lo tenga en el horario local a
lo mejor cargado el símbolo pudiera ser pudiera ser fíjate que lo tengas
cargado en echange el símbolo vale te enseño lo que lo que quiero decir
espera que vamos a sacar ya esto enseño lo que quiero decir vale es decir tú
cuando cargas un símbolo en el gráfico
puedes elegir aquí local o echange vale dependiendo del tipo de sistema si tú
usas horas y tú te refieres a time por ejemplo pues es time ese es la hora del
gráfico entonces tú le has puesto 9 30 y el gráfico va de 15 30 a 10 de la
noche que es lo que te pasa en este caso como yo lo tenía ahora en el local lo
que pasa que este este sistema en concreto lo veremos más adelante es un
volatility breakout no es un rv por lo tanto no usa horas y no importa pero si
tú usas horas pues puede ser puede provocarte eso que no opere vale que no
opere porque pues la hora no existe si tú le dices a partir de las 9 30 hace
x cosa y esa hora no está en el gráfico pues ese puede ser un motivo vale se me
ocurre que se puede ser eso es probable que sea eso es probable que sea eso
porque ya te digo es algo usual ahora ha caído vale bien qué más comentaba
Juan Manuel ya las de Raúl quedó la semana pasada voy voy leyendo respecto a
la configuración del money management para el sistema durante la evaluación
para saber qué exposición neta del sistema en porcentaje se recomienda por
consenso hay que apalancamiento y cómo establecerlo en código bueno no hay una
recomendación de apalancamiento no apalancamiento eso es algo que depende
de muchísimos factores desde uno personal vale desde el riesgo o sea en
evaluación preliminar lo que os comenté es que nosotros aunque también os lo
dije y os digo levantó que sigue habiendo cierto debate sobre el tema es
decir nosotros ya ya os explicó siempre os he intentado explicar las cosas que
que digamos la industria pues tiene ya establecidas cosas que al final hacemos
nosotros porque nosotros las queremos así entonces por haber distintas
opiniones nosotros creemos que es mejor usar
un money management pero es verdad que si tú tienes el gráfico ajustado si tú
tus esto se ajustan a la volatilidad puedes no es grave de acuerdo no es
grave que vaya todo el rato con un con un cotado pero es importante que se
ajuste y aún así habrán el ejemplo del nasda que es el que pusimos en el curso
es muy paradigmático no porque la variación de precios y miras en muy
largo plazo es es bestial claro un contrato del 2000 no es un contrato del
2009 y mucho menos el 2024 entonces si tú todo el rato vas con un contrato pues
ese es el problema entonces realmente usamos un money management que
simplemente permita que esos contratos varíen el que estáis viendo hasta ahora
en estos ejercicios que hemos hecho en la práctica es anominal vale que es
este tengo aquí un sistema que os enseñaré luego bueno igual de hecho da
igual porque todos iguales vale aquí simplemente usamos el importe que le
ponemos nosotros en la cuenta se multiplica por un multiplicador que es
vale que por cien vale lo único que está separado el dinero inicial la
cuenta inicial y el que vas ganando pero al final le ponemos cien iguales y la
realidad no está separado es lo mismo porque en ambos casos multiplicamos por
cien y lo sumamos por lo tanto queda que da igual y eso se divide por un valor
que al final es el cierre multiplicado por big point value vale que es el cierre
multiplicado por big point value el valor nominal de un activo vale es decir
en este caso yo estoy invirtiendo este este money management que ves tú
equivale a ir a cien por cien de exposición es eso pero simplemente es
porque para para mirar un poco cómo va el sistema pues pues usamos uno sencillo
que no tiene mucha mucha historia en las prácticas
probablemente a partir de la de cuando acabemos ya este este volatilidad
breakout o revés y demás que confío que va a ser hoy
entonces seguramente abordaremos algunas clases como llamarlas temáticas de
acuerdo es decir no sólo de hacer un sistema aunque en los ejemplos pues por
supuesto se pueden hacer sistemas pero pues ya ya lo comenté durante la teoría
y también lo he dicho en las prácticas pues por ejemplo pues queda de ideas por
ejemplo el aprovechando en la revisión que hemos hecho de apolo que lo comenté
y ha habido un comentario en el disco estoy de acuerdo que es interesante pues
bueno pues haremos una práctica de eso mirar un sistema real se sale de su zona
si pondremos un poco de esta práctica de un caso real de la revisión de un
sistema que está operando entiendes entonces creo realmente que es algo que
puede aportar mucho mucho valor
claro y por supuesto que es algo que iba ahora gestión monetaria ah ah ah
ah ah undaremos en la gestión monetaria de manera específica la
que la clase estará más enfocada en la gestión monetaria que en el hecho de
hacer un sistema como por ejemplo hoy estamos más enfocados en hacer en hacer un sistema que más